[Inaudible]
do you have other ways of saying no that you
uses sort of default language or anything like that because people see what you
do, right? I mean, you have so much in the air and you're,
you're getting so much done,
but they don't see the thousands of things that you say no to. Right.
I can say right now I am,
I am so honest right now.
I'm so honest that it is
it's so it's ridiculous, right? Like right now I am,
I am no kidding. Absolutely not. No. 40 years old,
I got time to beat around the Bush for no why? I just don't want to do that.
I just don't. I don't want to do that.
I shouldn't have to explain why I don't want to do something.
I shouldn't have to explain. That's a,
that's a thing that people have to overcome.
There's a portion of life that you go through where you feel guilty for saying
that you don't want to do certain things.
It's not fair because when you do want to do things as celebrations in his happy
times, but you're allowed to not want to do.
You're allowed the option to say, no,
you say no for things that work for you and good for you.
You can be saying no to opportunity for all. I know.
You're allowed the option to say no and to not
want to participate or not want to do.
That's your choice in anything.
I know that. And I make sure that I use my nose wisely.
There's a lot of yeses.
So when there isn't no understand that. For example,
I love my fans. I love my fans.
Take pictures of fans all the time, go back and forth with fans all the time,
make myself available before red carpets, after carpets move.
Premier's not moved to me as I'm out and about seeing them stop, talk, pitches,
videos. But if I'm with my kids, no,
Kevin, Keith. I said, no, I shouldn't have to explain to you.
I'm with my family. I shouldn't have to do that. I'm entitled to know.
That's why you got two options. You got. Yes. And no,
you thought maybe an air that's your choice. Um, is a yes or no.
So as you get older,
you start to see that a little more clear and I joke around about it,
but it's so true. You haven't noticed how direct and honest,
old people are. Yeah, for sure.
Have you ever noticed the old person does not waste?
No. Yeah. Do it? No. Get your up, buddy.
Whatever it is. It's, it's, it's that red.
Because they don't have the time. They don't have the time to play those games.
I don't either. I don't play those games anymore.